those were conversations that family had
with him about how dark his skin might
be when he's born what
yep Harry and Megan sit down with Oprah
was full of Bombshells from Harry
revealing he felt trapped by his title
to Megan's suicidal thoughts and the
pair being financially cut off after
announcing they were stepping back from
Royal duties more than two and a half
years ago I took matters into my own
hands it was like I need to do this for
my family but long before megsit Prince
Harry managed to make headlines all by
himself
in 2005 he wore a Nazi uniform with a
swastika on the armband to a costume
party then in 2012 he was snap partying
naked in Vegas
still the title of OG Royal Rebel goes
to the Queen's sister Princess Margaret
who lived by The Motto disobedience is
my joy the crown captured it all
Margaret smoked drank and was famously
banned from marrying a divorced man she
ended up saying I do to a photographer
then had an affair with a landscaper 17
years her Junior
[Music]
then there were not one but two
attempted kidnappings in 1974 Princess
Anne was nearly taken by a gunman who
stopped her car and shot four people
they said I had to go with him
um
I remember why
I said I didn't
I I was
scrupulously polite nearly six years
later the queen came face to face with a
drunk Intruder who broke into Buckingham
Palace and snuck into her bedroom who
you my name is Michael oh get out
meanwhile Elizabeth's third child prince
Andrew has found himself in the middle
of several controversies but one of the
most damaging for the royal family was
the 2011 revelation of his friendship
with Jeffrey Epstein who was charged
with sexually exploiting teenage girls
do I regret the fact that that he has
quite obviously conducted himself in a
manner Unbecoming yes I'm becoming he
was a sex offender yeah I'm sorry I'm
being polite Andrew has denied sexual
abuse allegations but was stripped of
most of his titles Andrew and his
ex-wife Sarah Ferguson AKA Fergie
separated in 1992 and then she was
photographed topless and getting her
toes sucked by a Texas millionaire
but arguably the biggest Scandal of the
Queen's 70-year Reign was this tragic
love triangle well there were three of
us in this marriage so it was a bit
crowded
Charles and Diana's failed marriage her
death and his cheating with Camilla
plagued the royal family for decades and
just recently the leaked audio of a
steamy phone call between the lovers
from the 1980s resurfaced on tick-tocks
[Music]